Grant Hill Turner Sports n-c-double-a
analyst he will join Jim Nantz Bill
Raftery Tracy Wolfson for the fifth
consecutive year calling the NC double-a
tournament and the tournament available
on CBS CBS TNT truTV and streaming on
March Madness live I'm looking at the
numbers here grant you're three years
older than Vince Carter and I think
Vince is coming back for one more year
yeah no no I am three years old I feel
like a baby 33 years old
but now he has been amazing and we are
neighbors here in Florida you know
obviously I helped recruit him to the
Hawks vice-chairman of the team and we
spent a lot of time on the golf course
and but he's been a great great addition
in the locker room with Trey Young John
Collins and as we're building a culture
with young guys his contributions in the
locker room have been fantastic and you
know by the way you can still play would
you rather have Vince Carter's career
dirk nowitzki career you know I take
either one of them you know I think both
of them were fantastic he's both so you
know what I love about them is they're
both just really good solid people and
obviously dirt you know has the
championship which is pretty fantastic
but I think Vince Carter you know just
you know I mean he doesn't get enough
credit for what he did in Canada and
making that the game of basketball
exciting and relevant and just you know
you see it now you see the impact is he
all these players from Toronto and
Canada now playing in college basketball
in the NBA and really just I mean I'm
old enough to remember I had to guard
him so I remember Ben sanity at its at
his height and just a fantastic player
ever do it we had a poll question if you
could start your team with any of these
power forwards McLovin give grant the
list okay Charles Barkley Karl Malone
Kevin Garnett Kevin McHale Tim Duncan
gotta pick one grant I'll go with Tim
Duncan you know I did too yeah well I
wasn't sure because I think Tim he had a
there was a team around him all the time
I don't think he ever had to be that guy
that had to get 30 points whereas Malone
had to be that guy McHale was not that
guy I think McHale is actually
underrated I thought he was unstoppable
his low post moves we're as good as
anybody who's ever played the game and
very good defensively as well but he was
in bird and Mikhail's her burden Parrish
and everybody else's shadow there but
you know even Barkley to what he did at
that size is is truly remarkable and
even Kevin Garnett was freakishly great
at that size so I don't think there's a
wrong answer it feels like Duncan would
win because he had more team success
Polybius I agree they all were great and
I agree that McHale was so underrated I
you know I was a Laker fan big fan of
his but he was as good as anyone but my
thing is with Duncan he did have a great
team around him yeah but do you think he
could have been that 30-point a game
player if he needed to be he wasn't a
good free-throw shooter and I don't know
if he had moves where he could break you
down I think he knew what he could do
well and and he mastered that but I I
don't know Barkley could break you down
Malone could break you down kg could
Dirk had range so I don't think Tim
could have been a 30-point a night guy
yeah you know even he I think he had a
couple of 25-point seasons but I just
didn't look at him as unstoppable
whereas Dirk at times Barkley at time
like those guys were unstoppable at
times in their career yeah no good point
your point I want to know you know when
you made the call with Villanova winning
the n-c-double-a title at the buzzer I'm
watching it last night and I'm watching
I'm listening because I want to hear
what how Jim Nantz sets it up and then
what is said before that shot is taken
by Jenkins
say they have a play now I don't know if
you knew it and you were you didn't want
to say what it was but in the moment
which I always define greatness what do
you say when you need to say it and you
said watch for Jenkins
he was the trailer on the play but what
did you know prior to that play that
helped build a nova win the national
title good question well I first of all
in those moments and you know this day
and typically you lay out and you let
the iconic voice of a Jim man yeah you
know hey let him make the call and I and
I it's funny I thought back to I didn't
know that they had this particular play
but so I didn't it wasn't like I'll be
honest it wasn't like I scouted
something and knew that they had a
particular set but when I saw Jenkins
their best shooter taking the ball out I
actually thought of a play that we used
to run when I play for the Pistons and
it was a play where Terry Mills another
guy big guy who could really shoot the
ball from the perimeter would take the
ball out and because he had gone to
Michigan the play was called Michigan
and I would basically bring the ball up
and dribble up the court and try to
dribble at his man and bring it slip it
back to him for a top of the key three
and Doug Collins who was our coach put
that play in and the funny thing was we
would run it any time during the game he
take the ball out he'd say Michigan and
so he and I would be the only guys that
would know that and so we'd come down
the court I dribbled into the paint
turn around flip it back to him and he'd
shoot us three and so in that moment I
was thinking of that play I was thinking
of Michigan believe about taking a terry
bill and and so that's what came to my
mind and and thankfully uh
Archie Archie DL Archie died econo
passed it back to Jenkins and he hit the
shot and it made me look good talking to
Grant Hill Turner Sports n-c-double-a
analyst he'll be on the call with Jim
Nantz Bill Raftery Tracy Wolfson this
will be the fifth consecutive year
calling the NC double-a tournament
there's a whole lot of pressure on this
Duke team and I'm wondering can you
quantify the pressure
can you look back at maybe the Fab five
with the you know the Michigan freshmen
and that was early in your career as
well that those kids as freshmen you
know they made it to the title game
back-to-back years they didn't win but
just the amount of pressure where you're
expected to win you're expected to be
great how do you think this Duke team
handles that amount of pressure and is
it summer do you think to the Fab five
well it is similar and it's similar in
the sense of five five were freshmen I
think the Fab five first year they
weren't picked to be the favorites and I
don't think anyone expected them that
first year when we ultimately played
them in Minnesota you know they upset
some teams they beat a very regional no
one saw that happening you know I think
this Duke team from from the time that
they beat Kentucky in the preseason back
in November everyone has had this
expectation on them to be the eventual
champion and so there's a little bit
different in that regard obviously the
next year when Michigan and the FAFSA
came back I think the expectations were
great and they certainly got back there
but to be so young and to not have that
one year of experience under their belt
and to have everyone assume that they'll
get there it is a lot but these kids
have handled it well obviously Coach K
is I think insulated them and prepared
them you just think about this season I
mean maybe they've had some signature
road wins they've had buzzer beaters
they've had adversity they've been
through a lot and all of those
experiences including those losses I
think have helped them and put them in a
nice you know position now that they
have a chance a realistic chance of
winning the whole thing if you when's
the last time you picked somebody else
other than Duke to win the title and did
you hear from coach Kay
okay so okay so just so you know when I
do my brackets I always picked up dummy
okay every five years or so I look good
and um this year yeah of course
okay thanks yeah would you know I
haven't coach guy he hasn't called me
but I'll see him in Colombia so I'm
excited about that
hey he ever giving you grief on your
analysis of Duke all the time yeah you
understand Coach K we have a great
relationship but obviously I'm grateful
that 25 years later after I graduated my
coach is still there and so you talk
about tremendous connectivity to the
program and to him that's awesome but
there's still a part of me that feels
like I'm 18 years old and I'm in trouble
when I'm in his presence I'll note that
ever change okay but wait be honest how
often did you get yelled at and how
often did Laettner get yelled at in
practice well part of the problem was I
was getting yelled at by both oh you
know I mean obviously in 92 look I'll
say this Coach K what I respected about
him was that he was hardest on his best
players and a lot of coaches will coddle
their best players and sort of have
whipping boys who you know who were on
the bench or more in reserve roles great
he went at Laettner hard not all the
time but he went at him hard he went at
me hard and you know that's what you
want you want to be coached you want to
improve you want to get better and and
he did it like my senior year you know
my senior year we lose an ACC tournament
before the NCAA tournament and we lost
in the game to Virginia that we probably
shouldn't want and you know he went at
me would that be after the game and
when we met in his hotel and so he hoped
he held you accountable he pushed you
and you didn't always understand it
maybe when you were a teenager but you
certainly now as you look back you
appreciate it and you're grateful for
that good to catch up with your grand
hopefully we'll talk to you during the
tournament have fun and thanks for
joining us all right thank you
that's Grant Hill Turner Sports
n-c-double-a analyst and he'll be there
with Jim Nantz Bill Raftery Tracy
Wolfson this will be the fifth
consecutive year calling the NC double-a
tournament for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]